also so ein bisschen ist mein thema die
steuer der staat wird mehr und mehr zum
verschiebebahnhof des geldes der bürger
ja wo man hinguckt wollen sie steuern
erhöhen steuer erniedrigen und das geld
von rechts nach links schieben für co2
und sonstiges und ich kenne programmiert
großartig 12 euro aber unser staat hat
so viel geld und was mich auch extrem
stört dass wir das zweitgrößte parlament
auf der welt haben nur die chinesen sind
größer und es verschlingt also auch
einen enormen batzen von geld und die
renten für unsere ganzen beamten und
politiker es gehört jemand an die spitze
dieses staates der ausgewiesener
finanzexperte ist und er ist auf keinen
fall in meinem ranking die heißt olaf
scholz ja da kann ich also nicht
unterschreiben und ich glaube ich habe
ich bin eine kleine mode unternehmerin
habe in meinen leben als mode
unternehmerin vielleicht 100 millionen
umsatz gemacht und was sich da alles in
den laden geschaufelt hat vom finanzamt
das hätte ich auch gern für mich und ich
bin dafür dass der der den kunden parkt
oder schnitzel brät den hauptteil vom
gewinn hat und nicht der staat dient gar
nicht wissen wie man das sorgsam damit
umgeht ja denn wenn du immer nur
zwischen steuertöpfen hin und her schunk
lee ist das heißt ja nicht dass die
wasserwirtschaft ist wie unter 1 wie
jeder einzelne bürger wie jeder
angestellte wie jeder mitarbeiter ich
zahle ich weiß es die höchsten
stundenlöhne in meiner firma zwischen 25
und 40 euro für
stylistinnen und so weiter und ich finde
ihnen gehört noch mehr dass der der
arbeitet wieder wesentlich mehr
motivation hat die er bisher hat aber
das war ein tolles plädoyer würde ich zu
100 prozent unterstützen ich befürchte
nur mit blick auf die nächsten vier
jahre mir hat dessen ich würde
vielleicht ich auch mindestens nicht
besser vielleicht sogar eher schlecht
aber ich habe einen punkt den sie
gemacht haben der ist absolut richtig
und das ist immer die frage was passiert
eigentlich mit menschen die viel
arbeiten und damit meine ich gar nicht
denjenigen der manager ist und millionen
verdient sondern damit meine familie
unternehmen sie damit meine ich aber
auch angestellte
das kann auch einer bilderschau soll
eine verkäuferin ganz genau und die
frage ist ja er ist unser steuersystem
eigentlich gerecht wir stellen ja fest
je mehr man arbeitet und je mehr man
verdient umso höher wird der steuersatz
eigentlich müsste es genau umgekehrt
sein der anreiz zu arbeiten der muss ja
größer werden also zu sagen ich bin
arbeitet noch eine stunde mehr und noch
eine stunde und noch eine stunde und
deswegen müsste eigentlich der
steuersatz sinken werden der mann
arbeitet und nicht steigen also wir
haben ein falsches steuersystem ein
steuersystem das
leistungsfeindlich ist der absolute
chance ist es doch so habe ich letztens
gelesen also das ist bestimmt kantone
gibt die sich darauf geeinigt haben den
steuersatz zu erniedrigen wenn man also
wenn man gewissen umsatz erzielt also
ich muss auch sagen ich finde das
steuerthema
lästig und leidig und ich befürchte auch
dass es steuererhöhungen geben wird was
ich immer besonders was mir besonders in
der ganzen debatte fehlt ist das dass
wir immer über noch mehr steuern
sprechen um es denjenigen zu geben die
es nötig haben um den sozialstaat noch
weiter anzufüttern ich würde eher sagen
lasst doch den menschen am ende des
monats mehr geld also der staat sollte
sich da ein bisschen mal zurückhalten
weil im grunde ist ja der staat
derjenige der der so viel sage ich mal
aus dem topf raus nimmt und nicht nicht
unbedingt der sich die
lebensmittelpreise der staat ist in den
verteiler mafia der fall droht sich der
bak hat lustig ist ja zum beispiel bei
mir und meinen mitarbeitern bei meinen
angestellten zum beispiel wenn einer 12
euro in der stunde bekommt wäre ich
dafür der muss überhaupt keine steuern
zahlen ja weiter
funktionieren ich zahle gerne steuern
muss ich sagen ich bin stolz auf meine
steuern die ich zahle ich würde aber
eine erwartung an den start haben
nämlich dass er das geld richtig ausgibt
ja aber das ist für mich der hauptpunkt
ich mich langweilen diese debatten ob
der steuersatz hierbei so und so viel
prozent und in der bei der nächsten wahl
geht es wieder gibt es wieder ein steuer
wahlkampf und man weiß vorher schon das
wird sowieso nichts davon eingehalten
wir haben seit 16 jahren merken wir
keine einzige steuerreform erlebt wir
können das hier ad acta legen unser
steuersystem ist so kompliziert es wird
mals reformiert werden aber was erreicht
werden könnte das geld das der staat
einnimmt ordentlich auszugeben und wenn
ich sehe dass meine steuern ich total
gerne zahle hier in berlin für solche
schulen verwendet werden da kommen mir
die tränen da kommen mir die tränen in
den augen ein punktwert vergeude zum
teil ist wird verbrannt deshalb ist es
besser mal es bei den leuten dieser wert
schaffen ja ich werde auch nicht so
defizite also ich glaube schon dass es
ab und zu mal auch einer steuerreform
bedarf wir haben ja gesehen von kona
sind ja die steuereinnahmen sukzessive
über jahre auf immer neue rekordhöhen
gestiegen hängt natürlich auch mit
unserem steuertarif zusammenhängen
zusammen mit der sehr gut laufenden
konjunktur
von daher glaube ich hat der staat sich
angewöhnen die politiker die regierungen
es war immer mehr dass sprudelte quasi
ohne dass man eigentlich urlaub steuer
zeit immer gesammelt gesammelt gesehen
habt ihr sagen mit oder hat als
finanzminister zu enden der die meisten
schulden gemacht hat von allem ja ja das
war natürlich dann in der korona krise
klar aber ich glaube also da würde ich
mir wünschen durchaus das geld was da
genommen wird nicht per se immer einfach
zu nehmen also der punkt den sie auch
gemacht haben glaube ich absolut richtig
also wer oder auch was sie gesagt haben
dieser verteil bahnhof den es gibt das
ist ja ein nehmen und man sagt ja immer
und man gibt es anderen leuten am ende
diese das thema auch kita frei also
gebührenfreie kitas beispielsweise ist
auch ein verschiebebahnhof der stadt
findet man muss immer wissen wenn auch
politiker sich hinstellen und sagen
jetzt ist etwas kostenlos es ist nie
etwas kostenlos ist zahlen dann nur
andere im zweifel sie oder ihre
mitarbeiter jetzt arbeiter sie das ist
ja der punkt ich halte einfach für
sinnvoll dass das geld bei dem bleibt
der die leistung dafür erbringt und es
ist nicht der staat
und dass auch die die ganzen
angestellten die unteren chargen wenn
die extrem entlastet werden ja wenn der
staat weniger geld hat dann kann er
seine
zusammengemixten leistungen halten immer
erbringen aber wenn die private hand ist
geld hat dann wird vieles besser als
meine sind ja gar nicht so weit
auseinander ich würde nur vom staat viel
mehr leistung ein aber ich würde gerne
dass er seine leistung einfach völlig
holz hat gesagt ich sichere
arbeitsplätze der hat einen geschaffen
da kann auch keinen sichern ich sicher
seit 30 jahren tot sind arbeitsplätze
und ich mir gehen ehrlich gesagt dass es
jetzt gar nicht persönlich gemeint aber
diejenige gibt ja auch viele millionäre
auf die nerven die sagen ja ich würde
gerne mehr steuern fahren es gibt
interessanterweise beim
bundesfinanzministerium eine kontonummer
genau für jene die meinen die zahlen zu
viele steuern dagegen im jahr so wenig
steuern würden gerne mehr zahlen gibt
genug unternehmen hat ja immer wieder
auch musiker die sagen wir müssen mehr
steuern zahlen wir zeigen jetzt zu wenig
ist ich bin bereit mir zu sein wir
können ja mal gucken was da an geht im
jahr dagegen zum teil etwas mehr als
10.000 euro im jahr ein bedeutet all
diejenigen die sich immer hinstellen und
sagen ich zahle zu wenig steuern ich
möchte mehr zeit die ducken sich schön
weg das ist eine doppelmoral die finde
ich echt gefährlich die ist auch
unehrlich und die ist dieser menschen
gar nicht würdig also die sind reine
lippenbekenntnisse noch sie mich nicht
hinstellen als große mutter teresa aber
ich hab ein ich habe ein großes herz
nicht unterstützt gern die leute direkt
die was brauchen ja die ihr in not sind
ich mache da einiges darf man gar nicht
sagen weil ich das auch noch versteuern
müsst ja was ich da so macht unterm
tisch hab ja wenn ich in klammern das
geschenk eine art der dies und das dann
der musiker zehn seiten formular für
außen und lauter es wird ein richtig
leicht gemacht so ein bisschen gut war
oder wenn ich meine ehemalige
mitarbeiter denen sie auch nicht ganz so
gut geht aufgrund wissen auch immer ja
ein lager dann dann muss ich das auch
privat bezahlen und darf das licher
spende programmieren aber so ist das
leben
und da weiß man sich auch zu helfen
lange rede gar keinen sinn aber ich
hoffe und wie man so sieht es es gibt
schon möglichkeiten aus großen
strukturen heraus zu wachsen das war bei
corona so da ist einiges jahr wenn es
mal ganz klipp und klar kommt und es sah
bei der wiedervereinigung so vielleicht
gibt es auch irgendwann eine tendenz wo
die leute hier wieder leisten und wir
wollen und sagen wir doch mal ne kurze
frage werden die steuern mit der
nächsten regierung eher steigen oder
werden sie eher sie werden eher steigen
was glauben sie wir werden steigen wegen
der billionen die korona gekostet hat
sie werden gleich bleiben weil ich
glaube christian lindner kann die ampel
machen inklusive steuererhöhungen
christian lindner kann die ampel machen
wenn er dann der tough guy geblieben ist
wie wir sagen ganz gute im lindner nein
es ist dass ich glaube dass moment
moment christian hat es 2017 als
einziger politiker von allen mal gesagt
ich regiere lieber nicht so also
steuererhöhungen völlig monolog anfangen
bleiben gleich es gibt keine sonst ja
ich glaube es gibt steuererhöhungen aber
nicht für alle sondern für wenige und es
ist ja ich glaube es gibt
steuerentlastung für kleinere einkommen
aber steuererhöhungen für größere
einkommen ich glaube es gibt
steuerentlastungen für kleine einkommen
es gibt keine steuersenkung für größere
einkommen und ich glaube dass die
sozialbeiträge steigen werden
[Musik]